What's Omar? What's going on, bro?
What's up, man? I heard you were about
to convert. I was like, "Let me come
through. Get that shahada." Well, yeah,
man. Here I am, man. Here I am. What's
going on with you, bro? Nothing much.
Nothing much. Just looking for this
answer, bro. Just looking for this
answer. Yeah. Yeah. I just I just jumped
in. I was like, "Yeah, maybe I can
help." I got about 15 minutes. Okay. So,
I'm just asking where does Jesus mention
Muhammad? Cuz the Quran says he does. So
if somebody could show me that, I'll
consider Muhammad to be an actual
prophet. Okay. Where did Jesus mention
Muhammad? By name. The Quran says by
name. So, but I I'll I'll allow even a
description. Name, description,
whatever. I think you have to stipulate
to a description because the Old
Testament doesn't mention Jesus by name.
So, it should be by description, right?
But the Bible, the New Testament never
says you'll find Jesus by name in the
Old Testament. The Quran says you'll
find Muhammad by name. Yeah. Now, you'll
find Ahmed. Yeah. That's a good point. I
would probably give you the Deuteronomy
33132. The one I've given you before.
I said Jesus, bro. Oh, Jesus himself
mentions Muhammad by name. By name or
description. Okay. That Yeah, I don't
know that I would say uh John. Oh, I
would do the the pariclete. Okay. John
14:16. Yeah, that's probably the closest
there. John 14:16 is where Jesus met
this morning. 1416 or 1426. I don't have
my Bible. It's it's all through there.
All chapter 14, chapter 15, and chapter
16. And they all mention them. All
right. So you believe that Muhammad is
the pariclete that Jesus mentions?
That's what I believe. Yes, sir. 100%.
That's what I believe. Yeah. Yeah. I I
don't believe in in general that like
the Holy Spirit is, but is the I'm not
saying the periclet is the Holy Spirit,
but for the pericletos in this verse,
that is that is prophet Muhammad for
sure. Okay. And so when it when it says
um I'm just Okay. Just to be clear. So
you believe that Jesus said this is a
prophecy from Jesus about Muhammad 100%.
This at least this part is the truth.
Exactly. So, so then this is part of the
Yeah. And and I will ask the father and
he shall give you another paric. He may
stay with you forever. Okay. So, it's in
So, it is actually in the Jesus is the
son of God. Oh, you're you got a low
bar. Got back the son of God part. It
says that in this list. Yes. Okay. Let
me see. Let me try to move here.
Usually, this part of my house is not
too good. Is it better now, brother?
It's getting better. Yeah. You got two
bars now. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, I
wasn't aware that it says son of God in
that verse, but Well, he calls back son
of God. He calls him he calls him his
father. He says, "I will ask the father
and he will give you another helper."
Yeah. Right. In my name. Okay. Yeah. So,
I would answer that with basically
saying what did the son of god mean to
them and first second century. Well,
does that matter? Is is Allah the father
of Jesus in in any way? He could in the
correct sense the father the originator
if if that's how you use it back then
could have been a name that Allah used
is a mother an originator not like the
father not like the creator mean not
like the I didn't say like the father is
is a mother an originator in the in the
sense that like she she has like babies
and kids yeah but not you know not in
the masculine sense the create the
creator masculine sense I got some hate
in the comments but yeah I mean so so
when we talk about I'm Sure you guys
will agree with us like with the Bible
and the Quran how you guys like why you
guys say he right for for the creator of
the universe stuff like that so you
would say that Allah is truly a father I
don't think we have a problem say it
again so you would say that Allah truly
is the father I would say that that's
what Iben Ib said with regard to talking
with Christians you're allowed to use
terminology it's not something I would
when talking to the Christians in debate
but when it comes when it comes to your
actual aka can you affirm that Allah
actually is a father oh okay so if for
Example, if I'm teaching class, yeah, I
wouldn't use that word. Definitely not.
So, Allah is not a father in any sense,
right? I guess. Yeah, they can say that.
Yeah. Okay. I know what you're doing
with it, but I understand my reasoning.
I know. I I understand your reasoning.
Just Just saying with your Akita within
Islamic Akita, right? Within Islamic
theology, Allah is not a father in any
sense. So, right with the right. Okay.
So, we don't use those words, brother.
Yeah. I know you don't use those words
but it's not just just that you don't
use the words this identity of
fatherhood is cannot be applied to Allah
at all right it's blasphemy to say such
a thing right that would be a blasphemy
and
biddy like it'll shik like take you out
of Islam I'm not sure it depends what
they mean right to be honest I would
have to ask the person okay so yeah yeah
I would I mean like okay for if someone
says that I wouldn't make tit on them I
would just tell them that you know you
shouldn't be using these kind of words
for sure because of the meanings have
changed Right. This thing, no meanings
meanings haven't changed. Meanings have
nothing haven't changed. Like like
that's this what I'm this is what I'm
saying, bro. When you when we're talking
about Islamic theology, you guys you
guys you you say that is like you you go
with the Sunnah and the Quran, but then
when it doesn't suit you, you want to
pick from the Bible to help your
theology out, and that doesn't work.
It's either the Bible is good for
Islamic theology or it isn't. You can't
pick and choose, bro. You get what I'm
saying? Especially when Allah is very
very clear on whether he has children or
not. Makes sense. Okay then. So, so what
do you do? How did you pick and choose
from 66 books or 73 books? What does
that got to do with what I'm asking you?
So, you're telling me I we can't pick
and choose from the Bible, right? You
can't. It's either the Bible's good
enough for you to have your Akita and
your religion, your theology, or it's
not. That's what I'm saying to you. Does
that make sense? like like imagine
imagine me if I was using the Quran and
I I don't believe in the Quran but um
when it suits me I pick uh the I pick
and choose from the Quran to help
formulate and articulate my theology
that's that I don't find in the Bible or
any Christian source but I can pull it
from the Quran. Um but everything else
in the Q like that's corrupted that's
corrupted. Oh this actually I can I can
work with this so this can actually fit
my theology. You you see how dishonest
that is? A little bit, but but
Christians have been doing it for
centuries.
Not there's not a single Christian that
has ever used the Quran as a source of
theology. Would you agree? Yeah, that's
fine. But I'm saying Okay. So, for
example, for Christians have different
Bibles throughout the years is what I'm
saying. So, how do you do you do you
understand the difference that we're
talking about here? Yeah. You're saying
I within the Quran because of the Quran
because we're two different religions.
So, exactly. So talking going going over
Christian sources whether they're
inspired or whether they're just
historical and good for reading in the
church that's within Christian paradigm
right none of them are going to go to
the to the Quran and use the Quran as a
deciding factor of what book is inspired
right right okay so so so let me ask
this make sure I understand correctly so
basically Christians all have the same
Bible basically throughout the is I
don't think that you're following the
conversation, Omar. And I might have to
move on further, brother. I might have
to move on. Okay. But you don't get my
question, Omar. Do you do you get the
topic? You mean the topic? Of course.
Yeah. Okay. So, can you use the Bible
for your religion, for your aka to
decide the identity of Allah and his
characteristics? Is the Bible good
enough to use? Definitely not. No.
Okay. No problem. Okay. So when we go
here in what you quoted, Jesus says that
God is his father. Is that correct
Islamic theology? Yeah. No, no doubt. It
is or it's not? I said no. No doubt.
Yeah. We don't use those words. Okay.
Sure. So G So you went to a verse and
you said that this actually this portion
is part of the this is the truth. And so
what we have within the angil is Jesus
preaching a message that is anti-Islamic
that goes against Islamic core doctrine.
Right. If that's what he said. Yeah.
Yeah. I I get your point. Yeah. So then
that would mean that the Quran is false
because if the angel teaches that God is
the father of Jesus while the Quran
denies that and goes against that then
the Quran's false. No I gave you the
explanation but obviously you you you
didn't like it. You know what was the
explanation? the explanation that in
debate you were allowed to use the word
father and as the originator Omar you
said in debate correct exactly okay yes
so you and then you also said earlier
that just when it comes to Islamic
doctrine Allah is not the father but if
you're debating with a Christian who
refers to God as father you can use the
term father in referring to Allah in
debate with a Christian so you guys know
what you guys are talking about. Okay.
Beautiful. But when you do that, you're
not affirming that God that Allah
actually is the father. Right. We are
not exactly. Okay. Yeah. So here Jesus,
we're not in debate. Jesus here is
actually identifying God as the father,
which in Islam is wrong to doctrinally.
Correct. Okay. Is that correct? Yeah.
Yeah. My my specialty is Old Testament.
Anyways, I like I rather take you there
with with this one. Yeah. This was a
little confusing. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. But
there's nothing there's nothing
confusing about this, bro. Look, the I
will ask the father. Yeah. But remember,
we don't get a So, this is just proving
we already have enough information to
prove that is the the son of Mary. We
have more than enough. That's not That's
not the point, Omar. The point is is is
No, I get your point. You're talking
about Islamic theology, right? You're
saying doctrine. Yeah, but I'm saying
we're not basing off the Bible. We're
just showing you guys this is where
Jesus spoke about another. Right. So I I
Exactly. So if so if this if this is
true which you said it is where Jesus is
talking about Muhammad another helper
coming Lord forgive the blasphemy but ma
another helper coming you're affirming
that Jesus's message in this portion
where Jesus says that God is his father.
So you're affirming this message that
God is the father of Jesus which as a
Muslim you could never affirm
Islamically. couldn't can't do it in in
the correct sense you could affirm it
brother is basically how it ended like
that answer it how how many times you
going to flip-flop on that bro in in the
corre the correct sense is how I would
say okay so so so to be clear I admit it
to you that we don't use that
terminology I don't care about
terminology I care about is Allah is
Allah that is that I question yeah yeah
so it so you're saying in the correct
sense Allah is the father of Jesus yeah
in the correct accents. Yes, for our
purpose of our debate. Yes, this debate
we can say that. No, I have no problem
saying it. Even tell me the the the the
fat was there. It's very clear. You
know, then I would obviously argue I
don't know if they just But speaking of
Muslim, you there if we can if we can
trust the Bible exactly for what what do
you think? So I I'm going to say it like
this. You want to know my final
analysis? Yeah. So straight up my final
analysis on who wins the argument um on
Muhammad being mentioned in the Bible
will depend on your paradigm. So if you
start within the Christian premise that
the New Testament is accurate and final
and ultimately your Christian argument
is going to win because it's
scripturally and cannibally consistent.
But if you go outside of Christian
textualism, you evaluate who fulfilled
the description itself, then the Muslim
argument becomes more powerful. So for
example um he was sent after him.
Muhammad right speaks only on what he
hears. Quran
5334 guide to all truth. Quran 53.
Rejected by the world uh uh praise and
glorified Jesus as the Messiah known and
recognized by all humans. Muhammad fit
all those descriptions. Right? So if we
if we go back we can look at the the
Christian claim of course, right?
they're going to say paracletos is in
every single manuscript, right? And and
it's never been a paracletos, which is
what um Rozi was like arguing for. So I
mean, if you if you focus on different
authorities, like you appeal to
different authorities, on some cases,
the Christian view is stronger and then
in other cases the Muslim view is
stronger, right? So if you only focus on
textual manuscripts, then of course
you're going to fall for the Christian
view every time because that is what the
manuscripts show and say. The ar the
argument from the Muslim is going to
come down to well those are manuscripts
written later on, right? And they had a
strong oral tradition. But guys, it's
not clear like in any case if you're
relying solely on the evidence, you have
to appeal to your faith and you have to
either believe in the Quran or believe
in the New Testament. And you you it's
so difficult for us this many years
later to try to say we're going to get
to a definitive point in the argument. I
don't I I mean Yeah. I mean, it sounds
like a copout, but that's the that's my
answer. Okay. All right. So yeah, so
where we're at right now is we're at
where Jesus is preaching a message that
a new comforter is coming and the father
is going to give him and Jesus as well.
Both of them are going to send this
comforter. By the way, do you believe
that Omar? Do you believe that Jesus and
and the father sent Muhammad? No. No, I
don't. Well, that's what he says. He
says he says the father. Oh, he says the
father will send him and and he also
says that he will send him and I will
ask the father and he shall give you the
that's the verse that I need you to
read. Yeah. And then also another verse.
There's also John 15:26 where he says
that I will send the spirit of truth
from the father. He says I will send
him. He also says that in John 16:7 he
says if I don't if I don't if I if I go
away I will send him. So we have both
the father and the son sending sending
the spirit or sending the helper. Do you
you believe that both of them sent
Muhammad? I would have to look at the
notes. I've actually heard this before a
couple years ago some on the Greek
um and then I went over with one of your
friends. Um I'll say
connection. Yeah, you're you're breaking
up. Look, we we'll talk again. I'm going
let somebody else up. We'll talk. Yo,
can you hear me now? You're still your
question about the Okay, for sure. For
sure. No problem. Sending Muhammad. You
said what' you say? You said you
mentioned the question to Omar a moment
ago about two sending Muhammad. Yeah.
Jesus says that the father sends the the
comforter and that he also sends the
comforter. So both the father and the
son together send the comforter. And I
was asking if he believed that about
Muhammad that that the father or that
Allah being the father and Jesus being
the son that both Allah and Jesus sent
Muhammad. Yeah, that that that's a good
question from his paradigm. I didn't
know did he accept the Bible? Was he
accepting the New Testament? He accepted
it when he thought it it lined up. It
was talking about Muhammad. Yeah, I
think it depends on that first, right?
It can't. You can't be a Muslim and and
possibly accept that. No, I'm saying it
depends on his view. not whether he's
Muslim or not, whether he takes the uh
New Testament as authentic over him and
if he's if he's conceding that it's the
the like if he made the argument this is
the right. Sure. What about what you
appeal to? You got to you got to start
from the front. Man, it's all about
framing the case. He's a Muslim. So, you
can't affirm something that directly
goes against Islamic doctrine. That's my
point. You Yeah, you should not. But
then arriving at what Islamic doctrine
is seems to be the uh question. That is
Yes. Ain't that crazy?